hello look at these cookie cutter
suburban households that looks so pretty
good fantastic evening all right
let's film this video all right okay
okay so I shaved my head I think it
looks a lot better to be honest I was
really postponing that my hair line was
like well I mean you can see where my
hair line is and I had like a little bit
of hair kind of like did I do this with
and then you turn my head to be all thin
up here looks like I'm not trying to
hide anything anyways so I'm about to go
to the gym but I just wanted to drop
some insight on you guys I've had this
concept on my mind for quite a while and
I'm really passionate about it right now
so hopefully I can take this philosophy
going forward and that is the idea that
self-improvement is not everything I
used to spend so much time reading
self-improvement books subscribing to
self-improvement YouTube channels
self-improvement subreddits and it was
stressful to be honest with you I was
not fulfilled I started to ask myself
how come I can spend so much time on
self-improvement books and subreddits
and videos yet still not be totally
satisfied like how come I don't have
much of a social life how come I'm not
doing perfectly in school etc etc I had
to go through this I'm like what gives
I'm pouring so much time into
self-improvement yet nothing is really
changing I'm not really like much better
off then I started to realize that I'm
not really doing anything like what I'm
reading self-improvement books like like
what am i doing real like what is that
accomplishing all these self-improvement
books talk about how to do things better
but if all you're doing is reading the
book instead of actually like reading it
and then applying it by doing things
you're not better off at all I'd read
are slash productivity all these
productivity tips would be up there how
to organize your Google Drive how to you
know make sure you're productive early
in the morning and I would I'd read and
read and read but I wasn't really doing
anything I did not take that advice and
then apply it to real life
self-improvement and productivity was my
hobby I wasn't actually like improving
the actual things in my life and living
those things
and I wasn't actually being productive
in those things I was just obsessing
over being productive and obsessing over
self-improvement instead of just living
so the point I'm trying to get at is if
self-improvement is your main hobby
honestly get a better hobby don't ditch
self-improvement altogether because you
should always be reading new insights as
to how to live your life better more
effectively etc but do other things man
here's a good example okay so these are
the kinds of books that I'd buy when I
was addicted to self-improvement the
4-hour chef creativity deep work
Thinking Fast and Slow why am i why am i
showing you the sides of the book the
richest man in Babylon the obstacle is
the way the checklist manifesto subtle
art of not giving a 12 rules for life by
Jordan Peterson great book think like a
freak how to win friends and influence
people you are a badass I started
reading it and I could not get past the
introduction all those books are like
self-improvement books productivity
books business books start up books
instructional how-to books and a lot of
the time I didn't even finish reading
them I just buy them because the act of
buying them gave me like a dopamine rush
and made me feel like oh I if I buy this
book my life's gonna stop sucking but in
reality my life sucked because I wasn't
taking care of those pillars that's not
a good I wasn't actually learning how to
enjoy going the gym for the sake of corn
in the gym I wasn't learning how to cook
so that I could eat better and enjoy
good food I was in expanding my friends
circle and becoming better at
conversations and just enjoying the act
of spending time with people all I was
doing was reading about how to do all
those things better
you don't win at this by reading this
you can read this to help you with these
but these are what it's all about the
way of kings by Brandon Sanderson
totally fictional medieval fantasy 1200
pages actually yeah it's like 1200 pages
long of nothing but made-up [ __ ] and I
am enjoying
the hell out of it this is helping me
just enjoy the present moment so anyways
I'm gonna start making videos still
about self-improvement for sure because
it's like this is a self-improvement
channel but make sure to use the advice
I give you on your actual life make sure
to hang out with friends go to the gym
eat good food
we good literature listen to good music
expand your mind work hard not too hard
be smart be charming and enjoy life if
you liked this video hit that like
button if you disagree with everything I
said make sure to comment it instead of
just hitting that dislike button because
that's just not really helpful I'm
starting a Facebook group in which you
can post your own productivity advice
you can listen to my productivity advice
we can help each other out like each
other's posts the link is in the
description it's a no-brainer to join
that if you have facebook join that
right now become one of the first
members the pioneers of the
self-improvement called better ideas
self-improvement hub and let's get a
movement going let's get a community
building each other up in that community
I definitely want to see posts
completely unrelated to self-improvement
sometimes if you just made yourself a
good-ass meal post that in the group if
you to have read Brandon Sanderson's the
way of Kings post that in the group like
what other fiction books do you like
what self-improvement books you like
talk about your life make sure to
subscribe if you haven't subscribed
already thanks for watching and we'll
catch you in the next video
[Music]